[Music]
hello and welcome back as they say in
the trade you're
uh watching the uh spectator uh health
summit and thank you so much uh for
doing it
and and my thanks to msd for sponsoring
the whole event now before the break we
were having a
a panel discussion about the nhs and the
shortfalls that have been exposed uh
during the covet 19 pandemic some of
them
structural some of them functional and
some of them
uh though very few of them to do with
the money side of things and
and that panel kept referring to
the care sector as well and i kept
saying we're going to talk about that in
detail next
which is precisely what we are going to
do the vulnerability
of the care sector and to be brutally
honest after a decade of diver
uh following dilnot and now nine months
of covert 19 in many cases misjudgments
those shortfalls have been exposed in
even greater detail
the virus itself swept through care
homes
causing further instability in the
structure of that service as well as
taking lives
all too soon half of pensioners are
refused help by
local councils causing problems that
that later place
further strain on the nhs
record numbers of elderly people are
being admitted with malnutrition and a
thousand
dementia sufferers enter hospital daily
as
emergency cases now although
the cost of care can mean selling your
home
care workers themselves are often paid
the minimum wage
so how do we better protect the
vulnerable
in care homes how do we ensure a
better integration between the private
bits of
care and the state provision
of care and how can we fund a better
system
that's been talked about for years and
years
but as i said has been a decade of
prevarication and delay
to help me and help you understand some
of these issues and to explore
possible solutions i'm delighted to be
joined by caroline
abrahams the charity director at age uk
by martin greene the chief executive of
care england
by natasha curry who's the deputy
director of policy
at the nuffield trust and by paul
berstow
himself a former minister for care and
now
chair of the social care institute
for excellence thank you all very much
indeed uh for joining
all of us um a reminder to people who
are listening to this conversation
you can ask a question of any of those
panelists
by writing in the text box at the bottom
of the screen or by emailing us
uh and the address for that is events
spectator
dot co dot uk so let's begin with the
headlines
what in your view panel is the most
pressing
challenge uh to the care sector caroline
tough question actually aleister because
you could pick so many i think it's a
toss-up between
people and money and of course the two
are inextricably linked so we know
that social care is a people business
it's all about what i do for you
whether that's helping you get washed or
dressed or
or if you're a young disabled person
helping you
get out and live your life it's about
people and there aren't enough of them
simple as that really uh in fact there
are loads not enough of them we've got
more than 112 000 vacancies in the
workforce
every day and i'm afraid to say we're
about to make it worse
because of the rules that the
government's intending to implement
around brexit and the fact that we're
going to say that in future people who
might want to come to work here as care
workers from our nearest neighbors in
the eu
won't be able to do that anymore so that
feels to me like shooting ourselves in
the foot
whether you're a leader or a remainer
makes no difference i think most people
want their mum to be well looked after
and
we're making that harder and that seems
to me daft
all right uh loud and clear people and
money
not enough people uh and uh being made
potentially more difficult because
changes uh
over brexit and immigration policy um
how does it feel martin greene uh
with your care england hat upon what do
you see as being the most
pressing uh issues right now i think
caroline's absolutely right it is about
money and people
though i would say alistair you talked
about 10 years well actually it's been
21 years since tony blair asked
lord sutherland to find a solution to
long-term care so i think one of the
challenges is this has been pushed into
the long grass for
far too long i also think one of the
things we've got to do is craft a new
vision for social care
so we talk a lot about money we talk a
lot about people
but we need to recalibrate social care
at the moment what happens is you only
get social care
when you're in a crisis and usually you
get it when you can no longer
make improvements so it is very much
that deficit model
and i think we've got to go to an asset
model we've got to go to a life course
model
and i also want to say just finally i
really want to reclaim that term
integration
because when people talk about it they
talk about the nhs they talk about
social care they talk about local
authorities
and in my view this misses the point
what you see is true integration
is the experience of the person who uses
a service actually what's going on in
the background should be the mechanism
to deliver people a good life
and i use as my analogy there the
airline industry when i sit on a plane i
don't know when i go out of austrian
airspace into german airspace
there's a massive administrative process
but i experienced a flight from a to b
and this should be the holy grail of how
we manage an integrated system
to look at the success measures and
measure them in terms of a person's
experience
not the processes that go on behind the
scenes
fascinating and brilliant analogy um
i seem to remember uh that the
it's an analogy that's been used in the
climate change debate as well about
the cabin not recognizing borders it
just
but it's a very very good one on uh
between the care sector
and the nhs um natasha deputy director
of policy at nuffield
trust we've heard uh powerful arguments
there
as it were from the uh the end user
uh represented brilliantly by age uk uh
by the providers represented
uh there by martin what do you see as
being the most
pressing issues for the care sector i
know
some surprisingly it's about people and
it's about money but martin's point
about
a lack of vision is really key to this
because if we look back over the last
21 years of failure to bring about
change
what we see is a kind of pattern a cycle
of
proposals being put forward about
funding that then become
very quickly politically toxic um and i
think we need to get beyond that funding
debate we need to take it out of that
sphere of that very politically toxic
sphere
and create a vision for the sort of
service that you or i might want if
we develop care needs and it needs to be
a positive
framing of that it needs to be about a
service that we want to enable
people to live independent lives and i
think that's the starting point and i
think we've
repeatedly started in the in the wrong
place
um and i think martin picked up on on an
interesting issue about
people's understanding of social care
and the fact that not many people really
understand what it is until they they
need it it's not like the nhs where we
have contact with it from day one
and we're very familiar with it you tend
to only find out about social care when
you need it and you're in the prices
and that feels a a low public awareness
of how the system works
the fact that it's not free at the point
of use um and the problems in the sector
so
it comes as a nasty shock to many people
that it's not
free when they when they need it and so
i think when we look back at the
the proposals uh around election time
2010 2017 for example we've seen
politicians putting
forward proposals for funding reform
which has been met
by uh public outcry because i think a
lot of whereas about 40
of people think that the service is free
at the moment so when they see a
proposal for
a funding uh reform that involves them
maybe contributing some more money
they think that's a service being taken
away from them so i think
there's a couple of issues here it's
about public awareness and raising that
and then it's about some strong
political leadership at the
center to really create a positive
vision to build that support
and then the other point i just want to
throw in here is
that we need that that framing that
vision to understand the complexity of
social care
too often i think the debate is very
narrow it's boiled down to
older people care homes and people
selling their houses
actually half of of public spending on
on social care is among working age
adults and
a huge amount of care is delivered in
people's homes so i think we just need
to
to nuance the debate and and to uh to
appreciate the complexity of it
thank you very much indeed um before i
bring paul in i did let me just test you
on one aspect of that natasha
because i don't want to misrepresent you
is the pounding heart of what you've
just said that come up with a
vision for what care should look like
in an ideal and then cost it
learning over the last 20 years has
shown that trying to cover something
before defining it
it's a fundamental problem and we've not
been able to build support political or
public support
change and i think that's where we've
fallen down i just wanted to make sure
that was crystal clear because that's a
pretty fundamental thing
um paul good good of you to join us as
well paul berstow former minister
for care um martin says it's not a
decade
uh of delay post deal not which is a
wonderful alliteration but it's 21 years
of delay
uh since tony blair first uh said we
need to do better
what's your snapshot paul uh
of the the state of social care and the
fundamental challenge that we all face
um all three of your previous speakers
have very perfectly painted
uh the picture which uh if we've been
having this event
10 years ago 20 years ago would probably
have been painted then as well
with maybe some subtle nuances to the
picture but it would have been
essentially the same picture
an underpaid workforce an unfunded
system
a system that most people know nothing
about until they find themselves in it
and an over-fixation of one particular
flaw in the current system which is that
some people have to sell their homes to
pay for care
so i i think there's just two or three
things i would say about what
the principal challenge is the principal
challenge is political will
and it's singular absence uh it's been
absent really for the last 30 years the
nearest we came i think in the last 30
years to any significant reform
was through the care act care act uh
provided at least the ability to
implement the deal not proposals
the deal not proposals would not have
solved all of the problems it was still
left issues of how you raise
sufficient money to pay for a uh the
state
state backed part of the care system uh
but it would have made some aspects of
it
fair and i think it would have brought
more people into an awareness
of what our social care system is so i
think there's two or three things i
would say one is that
it's not good enough simply to better
fund the current status quo so i agree
with martin's point
we do need a fundamental shift of
emphasis
to upstream uh preventative approaches
to this
not least because we're not just simply
talking about an aging population
some of whom will need long-term care
and support
but many of whom with the right support
at an earlier stage
in their lives will be able to avoid
much of the need for that care and
secondly there's an issue about the
working age population which natasha has
talked about
uh which often goes overlooked and yet
if we look at the
figures that have been published by
public health england if you are a
person
living with a learning disability the
likelihood of your vulnerability and
death from covid
is massively higher than many other
parts of the population largely i think
still under understated
so for me it's fundamentally political
world where does the block sit
the block sits in her majesty's treasury
department of health and social care has
developed proposals
numerous times there are only a finite
number of solutions to this set of
questions
they've all been offered in one form or
another over the last 30 years
the treasury has systematically trashed
each one of them
because it is really i think very much
of the view regardless of who's in
government
that this is an issue which it can be
seen as a can that can be kicked down
the road
and one that the government shouldn't
take the bill for
absolutely fascinating and thank you
very much indeed for that
um and and you uh paul
and also um i think it was natasha
mentioning the the working age uh
population and and and the fact that
they also uh make demands upon the
the care system but i mean i'm gonna
stick with you paul because you said
that there was a need for
uh political it was all about political
will as much as it was you agreed with
people and money of course that matter
but political will
what proposals specifically then do you
think
need to be made because you you said the
care act got a lot of it right that
progress was being made
that there was a need for more money et
cetera et cetera et cetera
boris johnson's put camilla cavendish in
there uh as
as the new as it were care czar camilla
is a former think tank uh
official uh great writer has written
very
movingly about aging and and about care
as well
what specifically does she need to add
to the equation so that she can take
a costed proposal as natasha talked
about as well
to rishi soon i can say come on guys
we've got to do this and we've got to do
it now
what what's the missing bit that that
cavendish can add
in bit uh i think that uh cavendish can
add
uh is uh to ensure that the prime
minister
stays the course that the prime minister
provides the political capital that's
necessary to get a measure through the
treasury
and then take it through its political
and parliamentary processes as well
i think fundamentally this is not a
question of
how much it costs it's not a question of
those issues at all in fact in terms of
the timing um i would say
in the wake of 2020
where the sums of public money that have
been allocated
to address the challenge of covid dwarf
any of the costs of a comprehensive of
the most comprehensive and most generous
form of reform
of social care fully taxpayer-funded
system
would be dwarfed by the costs that we've
incurred in the last 12 months
so i think what you need now is
the prime minister to get behind
whatever
camila cavendish comes up with as long
as it does
pull risk across society as long as it
does create a
fairer system of paying for social care
and one that everyone feels that is
actually going to deliver the right care
for them at the right time
in the right place and goes upstream and
prevents
need arising in the first place all
right natasha you talked
about come up with the right vision and
then
cost it in terms of specific
policy proposals do we have
the right agenda that that you and paul
burster and
and others can take to boris johnson or
camilla cavendish and sailor
his plan a this is this is what needs to
be done and by the way it's going to
cost x
which paul burster says will uh is is a
number that is absolutely dwarfed by
what you've been spending on cave in 19
is there a ready-to-go plan
not that i've heard of i if you're
talking about at the
the department of health i don't think
so i mean there are many voices in this
sector and a lot of part of the
complexity
and and that's why i think we need a
real really strong leadership
at the center somebody who is able to to
listen to all of those voices
that that understands the complexity of
the system to put in place that that
wider vision
and i think paul's right the care act
took us some of that way
but that vision really needs restating
and and
and putting out there and garnering
wider public support so not just amongst
the people who are now using services
but
the wider public who we need their
support to be able to bring
about this change so i don't think we've
got to step one really i don't think we
have a unified vision really
that's widely understood across the
political divide
that we can build support around amongst
the public
and until we have that i don't think we
can we can cost it i mean we have sort
of
estimates that people have put forward
based on the current system and
previous funding models etc but i don't
think we have a clear enough vision yet
to be able to say this is what we want
in the service this is how much it costs
and this might be the share of
responsibility between
the state and individuals i i don't
think we're there yet
all right caroline abrams you've got a
problem because
birthday says all you need to do is win
over the prime minister
get him to back cavendish uh and and
we're we're more than halfway there
natasha says
there isn't a plan there isn't a
clear-cut demand
you on behalf of uh particularly
people who have reached retirement age
and beyond age uk
does what it says on the tin um why
haven't we got a plan
why don't we know what we want we do not
know what we want but it's the mechanics
of how you get it that's
in question i think so well paul bestow
says you merely go to the prime minister
get his attention
uh and natasha says get the detail of
the plan absolutely right
and then put the price tag on it later
yeah but she says we don't have a plan
you say we do what is the plan
uh well what older people want
is they want social care to be there for
them they want it to be reliable
actually perfectly reasonable sensible
things that we would all want really
at the moment you know 1.6 million older
people have care needs and aren't having
them met
so that that's another example of how
bad the system is at the moment
uh they're prepared to pay something
towards it um that they can afford
so you know the will from older people
is there they're not they're not naive
about the fact that this is going to
cost a lot of money
um but but but it gets stuck as paul
says because
because there's no votes in it if you're
in government that's what they think
in fact they think it's a vote loser and
the last um the last uh
time that when theresa may tried to uh
bring some reforms forward you know she
got very badly burned as we all know
and that's that's i think strikes fear
throughout all politicians
but you know in a way i was thinking
about this we're sort of in the same
position that education was in in the
19th century we've got a a fundamental
basically public service here that deals
with some
you know millions and millions of all of
us um as we get older not not
not only us but also working age
disabled people as well
and we're still running it like a
cottage industry essentially there's no
i mean one of the things that's come
through the pandemic is that when
ministers have tried
to help social care they found it
awfully difficult because the department
of health didn't even have a list of all
the care homes there are
you know there's no there's a total lack
of structure and
and and organization and other countries
are showing that you can you don't have
to nationalize everything you can just
have a firm's
framework within which things work
natasha is a consummate expert on
germany and that's what they've done
and i think that's what we should do
that is a plan there are plenty of good
examples to draw on right around the
world
germany probably being the best and if
we did germany here i think agk would be
very happy
um martin greene do you think there's a
plan
well i don't think there's a plan and i
think partly because if you looked at
this from the premise
of what we need to achieve you would
look at it across health and social care
and the problem in this country is you
have health in one silo social care in
another
it is absolutely toxic for any
politician to start talking about
reapportioning resources across the
system because that translates within
the public's mind as you're trying to
get rid of the health service
or you're going to privatize it or
you're trying to cut it
and actually if you look at the reasons
why people need social care they need
them because they've got health
conditions
so i do think we should have a proper
discussion about
the amounts of money that are going into
health and social care
and how we apportion it and that does
not mean that the nhs
takes over social care and one of the
things that we
are really in a problem here is that
everybody talks about
organizations and they need to shift
their focus from organizations
um and structures to people and outcomes
and actually if we use the money across
both bits of the system much more
effectively
we wouldn't be going to the chancellor
and asking for quite as much as we
currently are
and partly one of the challenges is that
the chancellor sees how much money has
gone into what he considers to be the
system because everybody tells us
it's all integrated and in reality it's
gone into one silo
and rather than the other so i do think
there is a real need for an
adult conversation about how we
restructure things that are fit for
purpose
in the 21st century not in the 19th and
20th century
and let me press you on that and then
i'm going to ask the other three to come
back in on it because i think that's a
fundamental
point um martin greene
you're basically saying that
and i don't want to divide you but i
want to make a distinction here
that when natasha says
come up with a vision for what care
should be like
and then cost it and go to the governor
what have you it seems to me what you're
saying is
that the absolute first and foremost
ambition when trying to deal with
the demands of the care sector is that
issue of integration how care and the
nhs work together
not so much what is being done for
better or for worse in some places
brilliantly in some places
not so well within the care silo to you
the
absolute priority is integration am i am
i right
uh well the absolute priority is
delivering what people need when they
need it and delivering it at the time
that can only be done with a properly
integrated nhs
stroke care system yeah it can well it
can be done with an
integrated approach to the funding of a
health and social care system
so again focusing on outcomes not on the
organizations
and delivering it at a time that can
only be done with a properly integrated
nhs stroke care system yeah it can
well it can be done with an integrated
approach to the funding of a health and
social care system
paul bestow martin's right that uh
certainly part of the
answer here is to have a more joined up
approach both at a
national level in terms of the outcomes
that we're trying to achieve
uh nationally in terms of the way in
which resources flow
um you know we have uh not just silos at
a local level we have silos at the
national level you have
uh funding for social care goes through
uh the housing and communities and local
government ministry
uh and uh the policy for social care
sits with the department of health and
social care
uh an immediate fracture there which
makes it quite difficult
to affect change and then you have
the nhs funding which again is is very
jealously guarded
by the nhs when it comes to the way in
which they view that money being used
and yet if you took the principle of the
care act which was all about promoting
individual well-being and focusing on
that
and made that a common organizing
purpose of both health and social care
i think you would begin to break down
some of these silos it wouldn't be
sufficient of itself
but i think it will be an important
cultural and behavioral
shift that we need to see at a local
level i say that as the
chair of an integrated care system where
we are and have seen during the pandemic
amazing collaboration across health and
social care uh not just between
the public sector part of it but with
the private sector as well
we need to make sure that some of those
uh if you like
wartime experiences of collaboration
uh to make sure that we organize around
the common purpose
carry on now as we come out of the
pandemic natasha
really i mean i think um integrated care
systems
are an opportunity here to bring about
real integration between health and
social care i think
too often social care is seen as an
adjunct to the nhs it's a support
service and not a service of value in
itself and i completely agree with
martin when
when we talk about integration i don't
think we're talking about the nhs taking
over social care
it's a service in in of its own right um
and it doesn't just need to be
integrated with health it's also
closely related to housing and community
services so i think it's absolutely
right that it sits in the local
government sphere
but we do need the services working
together and we need to be thinking
about them as one
and i think what in the early months of
covid what we really saw was that
fracture between the two
systems and and the other thing that i
think was really highlighted is that
is a focus on on health and an absence
of focus on the nhs
throughout the entire system so at the
center and that filters
down and i think that's something that
we need addressing and so we need
a real capacity and capability
at the center to really bring this about
and then that flow down to integrated
care systems
um obviously that's a creating an
integrated care system
with local governments around the table
as an equal partner
has challenges and barriers but i think
there is an opportunity here
to really bring that out and finally
caroline i mean
as it were you're a charity raising
money to support
folk as they uh enter into their uh
their later years and
and live through that period um
in a sense they are the acid test as to
whether or not it works
does it in is it your view that that
integration that notion of integration
is at the pounding heart of it
um or or is it just a gentle segue
no i think um as we've learned
throughout this session really
social care does different things for
different people but for older people as
martin has said
actually almost everybody who's an older
person who needs social care
needs it because their health is going
downhill which happens to us very often
as we get older
we've got millions of people living with
multiple long-term conditions now
things that would have killed them 20 30
years ago it's a great
it's a great thing that now people are
able to stay alive with cancer in a way
they work before very often
but they need extra help and so actually
for those sorts of people
uh getting this joined up a service is
possible right around them works really
well
we've seen it i personally see that
there it happens at all kinds of
different
levels of the system for example there
are joined up
um teams now which work out of some
hospitals to help people stay out of
hospital when they don't need to come in
because
you know hospitals great if you need if
you're an older person but it can be
quite dangerous if it's not
and in those teams which are clinically
led you see
um social workers physios ots
clinicians nurses they all work together
in a democratic way
it works really well and you know
equally community services which i think
we've just touched on
absolutely crucial in this district
nurses help to keep older people going
but at the moment there's this very firm
demarcation between a district nurse on
the one hand and a care worker on the
other
which probably doesn't make sense and i
think camilla cavendish as you
you mentioned earlier on um alistair i
think she she's been
very interested in some of the models
that operate abroad which
which work very differently that give
more power control to local teams to
work
more across those traditional divides so
we need we do need integration at all
levels
and just one final point on that and i'm
going to stay stay with you
caroline if i may because natasha talked
about
in terms of that integration what have
you mentioned housing as well
so so that it it's all of it of an
holistic piece
uh as it were that's in my
experience that's simply good men and
women doing
a good job of work within their
bit whether they're a care worker or
whether they're a gp or a nurse or
or whether they're somebody trying to
sort out a housing problem
um does it need structural reform as
well
or is it simply you know the will of
good men and women doing the right thing
i think we need to get some of the
structural barriers out of the way like
yeah
i'm very interested in ics's integrated
care systems
because partly because they mean you
don't have to choose about who who runs
social care
so local government or nhs actually they
both get round the table and talk about
it in the round alongside the health
provision that
so many older people need so i think
that's a rather neat solution
whether it'll work out like that in
practice we'll have to see but i think
it's really promising and we're
certainly supporting it
okay fine i i want to move it on a
little bit we've got a we've got about
another 15 minutes
um maybe 20 minutes or so
there is a very obvious underlying
problem and that is
unfairness um whether that's naivety or
poor journalism i don't know but that
that's the pounding heart of it
um in care and it it's the simple
unfairness of
the wealthy versus the poor homeowners
versus renters
savers versus non-savers um
let me just put it to you all of you
life's like that
or does it not have to be do you believe
whether you go back as paul did 21 years
or
as i did decade to dill not on what have
you
that there really is a meaningful way of
addressing that unfairness
issue or that's the way it is and that's
what we have to learn to live with
natasha i think we absolutely don't have
to live with it
and and i think we can address we can
address it and
as caroline mentioned i've been looking
at different countries approaches to
this
i've looked at germany and japan
specifically and both countries have
tried
to make to create a consistent service i
mean you can't ever have perfect
fairness but you can certainly move
towards it
because as you as you as you mentioned
we have an extremely variable system
that's
incredibly unfair so unfair in terms of
your wealth in terms of where you live
in terms of if you have access to
to family members who can help you etc
there's so many levels of unfairness in
our system
and we don't have to live with them so
um
one of i think there are a couple of
things we could do so the first one
would be around pooling
funding for this i think that's the
that's the first step
at the moment the burden of costs falls
on the individual
if you have assets over 23 000 pounds so
you don't have to be particularly
wealthy
for you to bear all of that cost and so
that's one unfairness
your access to care can also um vary
according to where you live
and what council you live in how
affluent they happen to be
so the other thing that we can think
about the other countries have done is
raise money nationally to pull that risk
but also to make sure that you have a
consistency
in the benefits that people receive so
in both german and japan
they assess people using a national
needs assessment framework so it doesn't
matter where you live it doesn't matter
if you have dementia or if you have
cancer it doesn't matter if you have a
a carer at home family members look
after you or not doesn't matter if
you're wealthy or poor
you go through the same needs assessment
and then the benefits that you are then
entitled to
is based purely on your need and nothing
else and then you can access services
accordingly so i think there
are things that we can do along those
lines and and i think that
that model gives us a mix of kind of a
national
framework but then local delivery so we
can retain that
the tailoring that we need to local
needs
and that before i bring martin in
natasha that the german japanese model
that's an assessment of every single
individual
everybody in society when they they get
to age what 65 or 68 or whatever
in the japanese system is h-based so you
have 65
but in the german system any age and you
go through it at any point in your life
when you have a care need you feel like
you need help you go through the same
assessment so there's a total clarity
and a fairness and a consistency that i
think we so badly lack here
and and that's everybody it's not simply
somebody who applies
uh or a family that says look my dad or
my granddad is coming to that point in
their life
this is automatically done by the state
to the citizen
for the citizen well it's it's anybody
can can refer themselves anybody
right okay the point at which they need
help yeah they can prefer themselves
okay the other side of this just
around the provider side so the other
the other issue we have in our
system is that providers are unstable
they're finding it hard to make ends
meet
in the german japanese system there's a
set payment schedule which gives the
providers more certainty over the longer
term so that's another way another
mechanism we could think about to give
providers a bit more certainty
okay thank you for that martin how do
you address the issue of unfairness
i think there are several levels to it
and i think one of the challenges
is there's a great deal of ageism in our
current system so older people get a
much worse deal than some others
so for example older people services are
always commissioned by local authorities
in terms of block contracting so they
might say you're going to have a
personalized care plan but they won't
for example say
you need more so we're going to pay more
now that's a
marked contrast to how younger adults
are treated so i saw recently
a case of a younger adult with a 2 100
pound a week care package
and yet the local authority were only
offering 490 pounds per week
for an older purpose person in
residential care
and the person who was younger had
pretty much the same cognitive functions
as the older person who had an advanced
dementia
so i think the issues about fairness are
very
complex and they run very deep i would
agree with natasha though that we need
to have a much more open system where
people can refer themselves
and where their needs are the drivers of
the support they get
and let's think about a needs-based
approach but also an assets-based
approach so that it's not about what
people can't do it's about
enabling them to do what they possibly
can for themselves maintaining their
independence and their dignity and their
autonomy over their own lives those are
the things that we need to be focusing
on i think
fascinating and and segwaying neatly
into caroline i mean the general
question about how in your view age uk's
view
do you address that fundamental issue of
of unfairness
but but also if you if you would
reflecting a little on what natasha and
martin just said that
by assessing real need you make
sure that those who are really in need
are getting what they require
but also you may just be avoiding
wasting money as it were
on a challenge that doesn't yet exist i
mean
our view at agk is that uh social care
should become free at the point of use
just as the nhs
is because if you do that which is
essentially what happens in
in germany in japan there could be a
co-payment for people who are better off
that's not a problem
but actually you then immediately get
rid of one of the big problems about
joining up health and care which is that
they're funded so very differently
and it's important to recognize that
what we currently define as social care
in some other countries is defined as
health and in this country used to be
defined as health
so you could there's a social care bath
and a health bar for example
depending on the purpose you might get
it for free or not
so there's a load of jiggery potpourri
that essentially the treasury is
overseen
in order to try and keep the price down
for the amount that they're actually
having to fund
uh and we should we just need to move to
a completely different place
and part of the reason we haven't i
think i'm afraid as martin says his
ageism that
as a as a society probably not just our
country too i think we've seen a lot of
similar problems right across europe for
example in the developed world with care
homes during the pandemic
uh out of sight out of mind and we
haven't taken seriously enough we've
almost been in denial of the fact that
we will all probably if we're lucky be
old one day
and we will need help of some kind some
of us
but we try not to think about it as a
society and it's time we had a much more
grown-up conversation about that as well
paul bestow it seems to me that natasha
martin and now caroline as well are
all focusing in a sense on on clarity of
assessment
that that that as it were an
across-the-board solution won't
necessarily address the unfairness bit
as
as best one might whereas a specific
detailed almost risking intrusion but a
clear
assessment of what citizen a b c d
all the way through needs is the way
forward to really deal with that
unfairness issue do you agree with that
no
no no i don't i'm not certain that
that's a fair characterization of what i
just heard the others say
uh if i'm honest i think what they've
said to you is that
uh you need to have a system that you
know in a sense promotes
open access on the basis of need um
and the best way also to remove some of
the barriers is to make that free at the
point of use
so that people don't feel any way
constrained of presenting when they
feel they have a care need of course you
have to have assessment processes to
determine
uh what the level of need is and what
the most appropriate response to it is
um but again i would go back to uh two
things one um
this is an area of public policy that is
um cast into the shadows it's behind a
veil of ignorance most people do not
know about
uh the truth uh the dirty little secret
if you like about social care which is
it's not
free and the means test is one of the
harshest means tests we have
uh in our in our nation's mean testing
uh
arrangements and and it's only when it
people are in it that they discover
that and they get angry about it but by
the time they're angry about
it because they're also many cases in
formal carers
looking after mum or dad or a relative
of one sort or another
they're exhausted so they don't have the
energy to then go out and politically
campaign for change
so that's why you know my point if
you're going to if you're going to argue
the case for fairness and there's plenty
of aspects
of making this system fairer and again
plenty of
uh reference points we can choose to use
to build a plan that would be a
long-term sustainable agenda for reform
of our social care system
and we have them on our doorstep even in
the united kingdom we can look to other
parts of the uk
that have made more progress than
england has um
we could uh begin to move this forward
let me button just on that one it's a
crucial one ball
so in a sense it's like the old argument
about
means testing um uh whether it's child
benefit or whatever
you know the argument that to make sure
that those who really do
need what they really need it's better
to have a
open end and everybody get you know
there's no oh you don't get it but you
do
system because that's the only way of
securing it i and i'm going to ask
natasha to come back in and respond
after you've
answered that but that's what you're
saying is is
is an across the piece provision is the
only way of avoiding
unfairness even if it means that some
who don't really need as much support
from the state get it
vast majority of people would not choose
to have social care
if uh if they um they didn't need it
because we're talking about things that
are most basic aspects of living
getting help with getting dressed with
feeding with bathing things that are
about your personal dignity
so these are not things people opt into
or some sort of freebie
they are things they have no choice but
to take up because they want to be able
to maintain some independence and have a
quality of life um the thing that's
missing i think from this conversation
at this point is something martin said
earlier on which is that we also need to
be looking
back as to what we could have done
differently
to enable people to have avoided the
need for more intensive care and support
in the first place
that's where caroline's absolutely right
and where the potential
of integrated care systems on the ground
looking at those things together both
the health and social care
and as natasha says the housing aspects
by bringing those different dimensions
together we had the opportunity
i think to actually have a really great
care system in this country that really
does intervene and provide support at
the right time thank you paul natasha
did i misrepresent you
yes i think slightly so um what i was
talking about
with the needs assessment is at the
point at which you are you feel or you
you feel a family member
requires help in everyday life doing the
sorts of basic things that you might
take for granted going out to the shops
meeting friends getting dressed etc
your needs would be assessed and then a
care plan put in place this isn't as
paul said this isn't the sort of thing
that people want
actively you know unless you need it i
don't think we're talking about
misuse or overuse um i think this is
about giving people the tools they need
to live fulfilling lives so so
in that sense i was halfway there that
what you're talking about natasha and i
don't think paul bestow
disagreed with it although he wanted
comprehensive was his keyword
but what you're talking about is
application
intelligent individual assessment of
need and then provision exactly
so rather than just knock on the door
press button b and we all get exactly
the same
well exactly and it hasn't tailored so
this is very you know it needs to be a
very personal service and some people
need very light touch care some people
need intensive care
and it changes over time it needs to be
a dynamic system
um but you know we need to make sure
that people have the tools
to lead independent lives and that's
what we're talking about in terms of
fairness so so in that sense i was
halfway there that what you're talking
about natasha and i don't think paul
bestow
disagreed with it although he wanted
comprehensive was his keyword
but what you're talking about is
application
intelligent individual assessment of
need and then provision exactly
so rather than just knock on the door
press button b and we all get exactly
the same
well exactly and it hasn't tailored you
i think this is very you know it needs
to be a very personal service and some
people need very light touch care some
people need intensive care
and it changes over time it needs to be
a dynamic system
um but you know we need to make sure
that people have the tools
to lead independent lives and that's
what we're talking about in terms of
fairness sure okay uh unless i see
fingers wagging at me and i'm looking at
caroline though and i'm looking at paul
so that's okay
i'm going to come back in now and just
we've got about 10 minutes to go and
there are two issues i want to address
rapidly
um and and the first is cost martin
um i mentioned in the introduction the
fact that care workers are poorly paid
some
uh provision is deemed poor quality
there have been
uh various reports done upon that in
your sense
is there any way in which the industry
in inverted commerce can reduce
its costs effectively without losing
efficiency
so that the state is more comfortable in
embracing
what is a high cost but terribly
important service is there any way in
which costs can be reduced
well i don't think there is because i
think what we've just seen is that we've
got
um a costing model that is completely
not fit for purpose
of course there are ways in which we can
use for example technology
but i don't want us to focus on why we
use technology as being about how we
reduce
costs it should be about how we improve
the quality of the service to the person
who receives it
yes there will be efficiencies but i
think we should focus on that
i also think we've got to have a really
clear career pathway
some skills and competencies framework
for social care staff
and that career pathway should be about
how you have a career in social care not
a job
you should have training qualifications
and you should be remunerated
appropriately and i also think that we
should be looking at how we use some of
the training and development monies
across the entire system
so the nhs gets a hundred thousand
pounds a minute
in public funding for training that is
not available to social care
yet the same people who are in the nhs
are also in social care
i also think if we look at the
demographics and the numbers of people
we're going to need to run
services in the way we do we're not
going to be able to achieve that so
we're going to have to work smarter not
harder with our workforce
and our workforce should be enabled to
move across systems just as
our citizens do so i think we need a
root and branch reform we need some
really proper approaches to the
skills and competencies framework we
need to be rewarding people for what
they do
and the complexity of what they do in
the social care field
is equally as complex as what they do
sometimes in the nhs
so a lot of the ways in which we
remunerate people
need to be aligned i think in the in the
future
just i'm going to move it on to the
other panelists but just
hold there for a second martin because
towards the end of your comments they're
about
um the system um not being fit for
purpose and the need to think smarter
and clever
aleister kelman asks what about poor
broadband connectivity for those people
who are
now using key medical apps to uh to
upload
key health information uh we need to
address that if we're going to be doing
uh the sort of stuff that martin's
talking about thanks aleister kelman for
that what do you say martin
well i would absolutely agree and i
think one of the things that we've got
to do is get the infrastructure right
i mean i live in central london and i've
got appalling broadband
and frankly if i was relying on it for
everything that i do
i wouldn't be particularly happy so what
we've got to see
is some infrastructure work to make
things much more easy for people to use
and i think this also goes to the heart
of what all panelists have said
we must not see social care in a silo
actually if we get
really good connectivity in our
broadband it helps the mother who might
want to connect with the nursery it
helps the older person who want to might
connect with their service provider it
helps everybody connect with their
families
so this is about a societal need and so
we've got to put the foundations in
place
that will enable us to embrace new
technologies so i think the gentleman
was absolutely right to say that
caroline do you sense at all
that there are areas where not
necessarily costs can be saved but but
as it were
the model can be made more cost
effective because
it seems to me that none of you are
going to get the large amounts of money
that will be required
to have a properly integrated system
unless there is some sense of quid pro
quo do you do you see any areas of give
caroline
well i suppose the honest answer is not
really i mean i think we have to accept
that we
underfunded these services for the last
20 30 years so
i think if you if you as my colleagues
have suggested if you bring
health and social care together and you
start looking at what people
might need in more of a preventive way
there's always the hope that that will
lead to some savings later on the
investor save
kind of argument around prevention i'm
not sure how strong the evidence base is
for that and i think we also have to
accept that as i've said
given that 1.6 million older people are
not having their needs met at the moment
you know this is a big bill coming down
the track was absolutely
taking away from that the question how
we fund it it's
also it's not unlike that point that was
made earlier initially by natasha but
several of you commented upon it
that that with housing is a part of it
as well with with department
integration as it were but in the sense
of people doing the right thing and
getting it right
that in itself is efficient in itself
reduces costs
really good housing example what we
might be talking about there
is having an older person having their
home assessed for how safe it is
before they have a fall not after it so
let's put some
really cheap things like grab rails cost
about 50 quid to put a grab rail in
can stop an older person falling
breaking a hip
going into hospital and then needing
social care but we don't do that we we
only assess
after they've had the fall in very many
cases which is bonkers
that's a classic example isn't it
because you were talking yourself about
the japanese and german models of
of individual assessment and caroline
there talks yeah about housing as well
what what citizen a or b actually
requires do you accept the point that
to go to government and say we need
integration and we do actually need to
spend some more money whether you like
it or not
you it is incumbent upon the care sector
to come up with
its proposals to make it cheaper or more
cost-effective
must be more cost-effective in or or
to achieve better outcomes of what we're
doing potentially but i think caroline's
absolutely right i mean this is a sector
that's been underfunded
for so long and has so much unmet need
and it relies upon
so many informal carers working for free
to keep people ticking over
i mean i think we need to accept that if
we want a better service we need to pay
for it
um you know and where that balance sits
between how much individuals are willing
to pay how much the state should pay and
how we raise that money
is another issue but i think we just
fundamentally just have to put some more
money into this
system and to invest in the sorts of
innovations martin was talking about and
into better estates
i think one one area where social care
could
maybe show that it could be more cost
effective or more strategic maybe is in
the sort of
in the commissioning of different care
models so thinking a bit more
strategically
and further into the future about what
sort of of care do people want in 30 40
years time
is it the types of care we have now or
should we be thinking a bit more
imaginatively
about different different models and as
caroline said to invest more in in the
preventive side of things which
is okay i've not been strong gotcha
thank you for that
paul final point then and start with you
another part of that imagination is
resolving the balance between
taxpayer responsibility and citizen
willing to buy
private insurance responsibility um
is that debate still alive and burning
or have we resolved it what do you see
paul burster as being the balance
between
my taking out insurance alar dill not or
whatever
to provide for my care in the future uh
and the person down the road saying no
it's for the state to do it and you help
me vibrate your taxes as well
there's nowhere on planet earth where a
private insurance system to pay for
long-term care
has existed and flourished uh it's it's
a
completely fallacious argument which has
been disposed of on countless occasions
but is trotted out by the treasury
as being the way in which you can avoid
taking on a liability
um the only insurance system that is
likely to work is a social insurance
model of the sort we've heard described
by natasha in germany
and other models of that sort that have
been tried around the world
anyone who has been close to this public
policy area for any length of time
inevitably by force of logic realizes
that you have to go down
routes that do involve having a
conversation with the taxpayer
and how we pay for this through general
taxation or other forms of taxation
and that's where the problem lies that
most people don't
know that this system isn't currently
free
most people don't know this system is
currently unfair
most people don't know this system is
unfunded and for those reasons
that's why you need political will to
actually unlock those
issues and be prepared to actually have
the debate with the public about
what a fair funded system looks like so
natasha interesting point
that paul berto makes there at the end
because in a sense you've already made
your position clear on private versus
social insurance the first thing that
needs to happen in a sense is to
make sure that everybody out there be
they poor rundowns apostles or wealthy
people paying taxes
they need to know what this system is
about
how it works how it's integrated with
the nhs and how better one can do
with that integration before saying and
therefore you need to pay x y
or z there's a huge information campaign
to be done
low public awareness and that is one of
the circles
that's one of the hurdles we need to
come across because until we get
that public understanding we can't get
the public on side now
as paul says we need to talk about
general taxation wider taxation we
cannot rely on individual insurance it's
as he said it's
it's a complete fallacy that would work
germany tried it
completely failed um we need to go down
a
a national revenue raising route
to pool funding whether that pays for
free at the point of view service or it
pays for a partial service where there's
cost sharing
that's another question but the base of
this has to be risk pooling on a
national level
okay caroline your final thought on that
on on on costs and also public awareness
of
of what lies ahead or or doesn't lie
ahead for many of them
yeah i totally agree it has to be a
national approach
uh private insurance doesn't work i'm a
bit skeptical about the capacity and
some information
um campaign as well um you know even if
you put loads of money behind it
the public all of us are inundated by
information every minute of every day
getting people to focus on something
that doesn't feel meaningful to them
until they're
they're going to be in it is going to be
impossible so it does take a government
with the guts frankly
and and the morality and the moral
imperative to say we're going to change
this this has to change
and to lead a conversation and to be
prepared to take on some of those
difficult arguments
not an easy ask i know but uh it
probably explains why we are where we
are now
nicely but final word from you martin
bring that
all together for me i think um everybody
has made some really useful points and i
agree with caroline
actually if we get the system right we
don't need a public information campaign
because we'll have a system
that will be fit for purpose when people
need it and that should be our goal
when we re-craft a vision for social
care
i'm grateful uh martin green chief
executive of care england caroline
abrams
the charity director at age uk natasha
curry deputy director
of policy at the muffin trust and paul
berstow
uh himself a former minister for care uh
and chair of the social care institute
for excellence
thank you all very much indeed uh but
that
concludes our second panel thanks to all
of them
for taking part and indeed to our
sponsors msd
for making all of this possible
[Music]
you